welcome to this video playing snuba from
Germany yes that's right okay this is
often really there recently lost some
game there yeah he's some very quick
player I have my doubts about the moves
quite often but he's quick so won't be
won't be that easy let's see why what is
he playing for playing for ok still of
playing for f5 not form for the Queen
side ok this is quite often useful and
here we go so want to play quite often
they take and play 95 and then c4 is
hanging so I like to put this in but can
also prove beginning ok FB five ok
controlled cannot play that and I have
all pieces there and play on the in the
central struggle and on the King side
and it's often a problem for black he
has to he has less space and it's
difficult to keep the tension so ok here
i can take and put this night on f4 that
was a bit dicey I mean d-texas d takes
d5 is horrible but you never know you
never know yeah okay here White's idea
is to use the weekend d 6 square
just steps into the hall let's see trade
this off
debatable that's a debatable move but if
I've is an annoying piece and I try to
be quick there
you
hmm a chick with a night take there and
what does it do I don't I don't get any
of those muscles sorry it can't
understand anything but that's normal I
never understand what he plays and then
he wins on time somehow okay now i have
95 right in this quite good
k 96 or just going back okay put it only
six
okay hmm so it doesn't mind the traits
okay let's do that so so what is this
point this point is that and that my
bones are all on light squares probably
okay let's approach this Queen f6 form
and maybe h3 was better anyway
yeah that was better anyway should have
played played this possibly g4 just to
kick him away then I'd have a good
square for the king okay let's do this
no egg detector and take his weaknesses
for once
check check I can take him with the
Queen on edge fun that's that's
something that I did not see if
beforehand
so take sticks if we take everything ice
quick i was asking there but when we
trade everything there King I fa5 okay
he cannot trade down to the king and
ponent game
ok
let's still somewhat tricky to play
that's it's really really the case
Bishop f5 is there check well that is
there are checks definitely but an
important one check on d to King age
three Queen age six check it's quite
annoying time wanna take this though
check check check check no it's just a
draw probably ever check I don't know I
always have this kind of program against
this guy I don't know what it is check
cannot avoid it check check check game
draw yeah sometimes nothing's ever going
to going to work out so here and Bishop
f5 is not winning on what yeah Bishop g4
maybe or something that it still it
shouldn't really come to this situation
but somehow it wasn't that easy all of
the sudden maybe 96 wasn't that great I
don't know g7 takes takes takes okay I
lost time there h3 is better of course
immediately getting this is just losing
a move and Sean I should play age for
myself this is giving him giving him
some counter play for sure
Oh Katie I should start with the check
the check and maybe go back yeah you can
play that more precisely of junk check
yeah Queens you three a five is the
computer move yeah this is a in fact
this is a pretty decent situation for me
there it's not quite clear what blacks
movers my queen is protecting the most
important squares there and if he if he
retreats I have this idea and I was
tricky I am I don't know Jim I could
have traded maybe yeah now i don't i
don't really fare well against this
player I don't don't know what it is
thanks for watching